I'm a firefighter slash EMT I recently
and recently I went on a call where a
patient didn't live not unusual by any
means
unfortunately I deal with loss of life
on almost a daily basis I detach and do
my job always working to get better this
call I failed to detach it hit me hard
when the patient's husband let out a
chilling let out chilling screams as his
thirty year old wife went from alert in
talking to dead within minutes
I let myself enter into his shoes at
that moment I got over it quick during
my days off and moved on it's part of
the job and I accept that but my
question is when does it become inhumane
to detach do we sometimes need to let
some weakness through to remain grounded
when dealing with such major incidents
as loss of life okay first of all
sympathy and empathy are not weaknesses
they're not weaknesses in fact it
actually takes strength to be able to
deal with these types of the situations
and these types of emotions the weak
move would actually be to cut those
emotions off completely so that being
said as you know obviously there is a
dichotomy because you cannot let the
emotions overwhelm you as a matter of
fact if you get overwhelmed by your
feelings then you can't do your job
properly which in its own right is
inhumane because now you're not able to
treat the patients that you're trying to
save because you're getting too
emotional about it
so what do you have to do the answer for
the for the millionth time of a
different subject but comes up all times
you've got to find balance you have to
find balance between being emotional
enough about not being too emotional you
have to learn to recognize if you're
going too far in one direction or the
other you have to do a self-assessment
you have to look and see and make sure
that the that you see the people you're
treating as people
you have to look at them and make sure
that you're seeing them as people that
you're not seeing them as a hunk of meat
right you have to do that you have to
make sure that you're doing that at the
same time you cannot afford emotionally
to go through the pain of loss every
time you see someone die cuz that's also
gonna be a problem you can't afford
emotionally to do that you can't go
through that pain over and over and over
again so you have to like you said you
have to detach normally do a good job
with that um I've seen guys get wounded
I've seen guys get killed I've been
around a lot of death and when when it
was around me I didn't have time to stop
and think about it I had to work to do
I had to detach myself and do my job at
the same time when it's over and that of
time was appropriate it's like you got
to connect with what happened and make
sure that you are dealing with it
appropriately and you know I always
thank firefighters and paramedics and
EMTs and and police and military but you
know paramedics and EMTs you're only
showing up if someone is in a bad way
and I know that's hard physically and
it's hard mentally and it's hard
emotionally so find a balance keep
yourself balanced make sure you're not
going to form one direction or the other
and thanks for doing your job man that's
like easy but sometimes you forget that
about EMTs yeah fire friendly that's the
only time you know where they spray I
mean pretty much yeah no getting called
because someone is in a bad way that's
the whole thing what they're showing up
for man and you know cops too like like
it's easy to be on the outside when
you're going to parks and you know and
if your job is like you know me I press
record and make the or make videos or
whatever you know and this is like every
day so it kind of forms this kind of
vision you know my
world whatever but EMTs and every day
everytime you get the call it's just
it's just the question is just oh how
bad yeah you know that's what it is how
bad how bad of a situation is the person
I'm about to go content with what's
their situation yeah they are they could
be everything from a minor situation to
they're going to die in front of me
again again it's a new person will and
their life and their kids and their
family and you know Peter Tia talked
about some of that the becoming a bit
jaded in fact it's a pretty horrific
story and it's worth listening to that
podcast when he was on and he talked
about how he got to a point where some
patients he started to look at I like
Matt he'd be mad at them yeah mad at
them and that's what you have to avoid
is getting to this point you got to you
got to do your best to stay emotionally
detached enough that you can do your job
but at the same time you can't be
looking at other human beings as if
they're just a piece of meat yeah so
hard job